Madison Square Garden my pants ripped in
the back
ripped totally in half I mean I copped
open it's so embarrassing
that was our first interview with a 19
year old Jessica Simpson just days after
her debut album drop
just posted this shots in honor of
turning the big 400 tomorrow and we love
that 20 years 7 albums three kids and a
billion-dollar fashion empire later
she's still that same girl it's tellin
it like it is I'm a loose cannon somehow
always make for a one-liner when I get
pregnant I'd blow up my feet were so
swollen I didn't have an ice pack I just
use chicken I am bikini ready yeah just
looks amazing with their toned legs and
tight tummy my mom has been keeping up
with her workouts during quarantine
getting in between 10 and 14 thousand
steps a day I think being a mom is
enough of a diet but I do eat a lot of
their corn dogs so I have to get on the
treadmill a lot to watch my TV shows a
source tells us Jessica's eating healthy
in moderation which has helped maintain
her hundred pound plus weight loss since
giving birth to Bernie in March 2019
[Music]
as for Jessica and Eric's relationship
she calls him her perfect soul mate on
July 5th they celebrated six years of
marriage they've been together for 10
and Eric gifted Jessica this butterfly
shaped crystal he's really like the
backbone to Who I am the moment I said I
was gonna stop drinking he gave it up to
Jess has always been an open book about
her struggles from alcohol addiction to
tummy tucks and a super tough pregnancy
but she's never lost her since the fewer
remember the broken toilet seat and
swollen ankles and people need true yeah
another thing we love she never stops
dreaming could you ever do a Vegas
residency I would do Broadway before I
would do Vegas
yeah Broadway dreams of course I'm like
a power ballad singer
[Music]
I'm very happy but I am not standing
still this I'm gonna let it shine my
biggest success in life is being married
and having babies I love when they go
out the door always be kind sit with the
lonely kid you're an intentional mother
we pray for the Mean Girls
[Music]